good [ __ ] no it's not hot let's just
watch it oh man dudes Monday [ __ ]
[ __ ] suck Christmas how did you say it's
called I suck Chris and it's great it's
[ __ ] rock but I don't know if it's [ __ ]
suck suck Chris all right but see I'm
not doing that for ya
don't don't know if I see a mistletoe
huh suck it old man see you see the
mistletoe yeah [ __ ] it
nope I'm not going to all right dude let
me ask you a question since we're
getting out a little bit oh yeah a
little bit we're gonna do it right we
just saw our girlfriend slash boyfriend
yeah dude I went there earlier because
you know I do blow a boat for this I
went there in the morning she saw boys
she looks she what's it looks good right
nails you see the fake nails song how
about the earring and the earring and
the point I know I'm a little right now
I'm a little confused
do you not know why it's fair to say
that's an attractive human yeah cuz well
I wanna a know-it-all have a she goes
the usual she goes nice hat
yeah my mother said to me once she hates
you my mother said I know she gives me
nothing don't like old well I'm an old
man shedding like ranks now my mother
one time said mother the kid was putting
one of our my little niece was putting
everything in her mouth saying little
kids did they they put spoons they put
some use everything yeah so and that's
how they build their immunity and all
that and my mother said you did that
everybody did the same thing and that's
why and she pointed to like a comb and
she goes do you know what that feels
like in your mouth and I go I kind of do
I do I know what a comb feels like a
mouth cuz I'm I can imagine what it
feels like I'm mouth cuz I had it in
round because that's right as a kid you
put everything in your mouth every kid
does where you going with this I'll tell
you where it's gonna be a difficult
question an uncle came along with a no
that's not what I was gonna say I'm
gonna ask you think of a think of a dong
that's ten-hut
I mean hard I mean purple all right dude
this this in this case imagine we were
listeners on Christmas Day you imagine
in your mind like listen some some some
dudes like oh they're my favorite here
I'm gonna play this for the family you
know I support fighting the kid I want
my family become Potter's play your
anyway listen
it's [ __ ] keep going
[ __ ] now you're rooting out alright
knows you're uncomfortable and I know
I'm not she like can you imagine what
it's what what it would feel like in
there a really difficult question
thrilled a question Brian hey I said
with a gate question I'm asking you an
honest question to be the gayest can't
you be honest can you can you imagine it
not really you can't huh no can you I
can't
hey hey what no it's no it's [ __ ] suck
Christmas we and I used to be honest
yeah Santa's listening yeah Elf on the
Shelf right listen Elf on the Shelf sure
how's the dick ever touched your mouth
okay listen listen Brian the answer
where would like my mouth are my cheek
you're not I'm saying nope I'm just ask
as ever been close to your mouth listen
sometimes you're with your body I rest
my case
listen hold on you can't just you can't
say that you're a young man Your Honor I
really see me right now you're a young
man your friend cause as a judge you and
your money PA hold on you and your buddy
pick up two girls at the beach sure you
go back to the hotel you guys are kind
of like everybody's getting involved
slippery everybody's getting involved
slippery and then and then he's moving
I'm moving then tank and it hits me in
the face
I've had that happen yeah I've gotten
hit by a good friend in the face you
understand me yeah wash it off and
listen me I don't give a [ __ ] what
you've done when you were younger
cuz when you get drunk you look at me
soft right and what about you've never
been drunk the other no I actually we
haven't I never know we really well I
get drunk now but now you get your baby
drink I just have a double whiskey I'm
good i double whiskey oh dude I forgot
to tell you in La Jolla yeah see this
group walk in 25 older white people like
that's weird not my demo they go they
bought tickets months ago one of the
older guys is a fan his whole family's
here for Christmas they don't know who
you guys are but they brought he brought
25 tickets all right cool Jesus sure
took tickets away from real fans
whatever you
one out of the show anyway the song goes
up you know Asad nice Indian fellow from
San Jose goes up has a bit referencing a
play with a Nazi in it and says some
reference it's funny bit that set
reference Nazi one of the older white
girl I remember that one older what yeah
you've heard is bit yeah well the older
white ladies in the crowd it gets logos
what's wrong with Nazis what's wrong
with Nazis ah but I'm not you know I'm
not like not like Kathleen be like
what's wrong with not like if you said
something about black people or Asians
like what's wrong with Asians you know
like dead serious they couldn't you know
what's wrong with not season the whole
Celtic uh and it's Anya's excuse me she
doubles down what's wrong with Nazis and
he's like Rose her a little bit but then
ignores it
she keeps hassling keep secular I'm in
the back watch I have security if she
keeps doing that I don't give a [ __ ] how
many because they bought you got to get
them out of it we can't have this that's
right they go we'll focus on it all
right Derrick goes up you know Derrick
you know yeah
Derrick goes up does a reference about
you know something he's talking about
something she happens him he says
something out her being a Nazi Baba he
keeps going she takes up martini glass
throws it as hard as she can at him and
she's probably we're chin is to me she
hits him with Mario that's a [ __ ] yeah
and the whole crowd just booing her
boner Derrick off see lights are up icon
stage she not get thrown out she got
thrown out oh she just done it yeah cops
got called yeah that's a real piece of
[ __ ] that I was thinking right those
other twenty four older white people are
left the brass [ __ ] 60o she's not
school not see yeah and I've been a bad
drunk yeah so you couple that up when
you put an Indian guy in a black guy up
there and then I look she's not happy
and then they saw that but I thought
maybe the whole squad was like they're
like Oh God so I go up there right so
I'm making fun of them are you know if
they say nothing they see nothing after
that she is thrown out show goes
fantastic because that gave us material
right shows fantastic
I get offstage they're all waiting in
like I'll [ __ ] some of the you guys back
to watching he [ __ ] up 24 older white
neo-nazis get ready everybody get your
camera's out yeah they were so
embarrassed they were it was like a
company thing they were so in they're
like we're so sorry they were there just
to apologize yeah they're like we didn't
know we had no idea she's dealing with
some stuff you know we don't know her
that well she doesn't like Nazis beings
you don't you and dealing cell phone
well she's a Nazi so yeah she's dealing
with some stuff he was playing hard to
find a group for her Wow Wow
they won't let us know what we can do a
bomber to it don't buy merch I don't you
rockin my [ __ ] and the only leave when
they said heil hitler i'm like well that
was why there i was weird their Heil
Hitler
there it is yeah yeah they crazy alright
who stepped the hell out crazy yeah it's
funny though I like I don't know what it
is and all do you feel the tension in
the crown house like oh this is cool
this is where like some of the worst
scenes been at the comedy store and I
love those crowds always really loose
but you get certain you get some people
a lot of military a lot of bros well
yeah this one girl that we had a lot of
military there this one girl who I
didn't know who was a feature when I
first did stand-up there are like and
maybe she was the emcee or making fun of
the military this was 10 15 years ago 15
years ago being fun knowing well she was
being like a little mad about it to like
flip oh and these Rangers were there and
that they're usually play but they
weren't [ __ ] having it she wasn't
funny what you just like I can't do that
anyway there was uh there were three or
two there were two marine through there
before who were so hammered
they were just like guys got to go well
then they DME like dude we are hammered
they kicked us out we've been failed I'm
like I can't control there is there is
that rusty Dewey
do you remember rusty doing [ __ ]
hilarious I love rusty bring it's not
rusty rusty was always a comic store
regular and and great and and there's
this there's this woman
this [ __ ] in the front yeah I will
never forget this she's an [ __ ] and
she's she's just being such a pain in
the ass and he goes he just finally goes
okay I'm stopping until you leave and
she goes you're joking they're his and
as he goes you're joking and he goes no
ma'am I'm not that shredded rusty was
always working out he would he would
jump rope for one hour straight hell
that but he's such a good guy I love him
and look I got a total Comics comic like
that you know and he he goes no ma'am
I'm not joking I'm a professional
comedian and I'm not joking so I'm gonna
sit here until they throw you out oh
[ __ ]
and she goes John no photo she was a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and and so she says my
husband's a Navy SEAL you [ __ ] and
and her husband gets up he gets up he is
just a little thick he's just a little
thick with a shaved head
and he's older he's probably 38 maybe 40
probably not still in service no he's
still in the service okay and there with
another couple this guy's big - OH
so they get up and he says something
like she says yeah you're lucky yeah you
got you watch your mouth and he goes
well you should watch your mouth I mean
you know I'm surprised your husband
doesn't slap it for you right now the
guy stops turns and looks and yes and he
starts to move towards the stage rusty
who's smaller than I am yeah thinner
than I tell you the small yes he gets
into sort of a stance I you know me I
look Brennan I'm telling you if you go
what do you do but he was he went come
on come on cuz Rusty's cagey and rusty
doesn't give a [ __ ] so cut rusty go on
let's go come on he's doing this he's
like he's got one hand out and he's
waving him in like this like a karate
and and but but rusty was pissed and I I
took one look at this guy's back and
neck and you better be Brennan shop if
I'm gonna fight this guy he's that thick
I mean you better be Brendan jump in
then yeah I mean yeah
he's a Navy SEAL he's probably a SEAL
Team six who knows what he is he's been
in the team's a long time which means
you're gonna lose an eye and maybe get
your nose bit off if he starts to lose
its not gonna be
he's Pete these guys waiting for vodka
keeps maybe he's got a knife whatever
the case violence is not something he's
a stranger to know so Russ he's gonna
get eaten I'm gonna eaten but you know
me I have a big ego down for it well I'm
not down for anything but I'm I have to
do something cuz I kill your friend you
as much as I talk as much as I train
yeah I have to do something yeah but so
the bouncers somehow calm him down and
move him to the back well they let them
stay but the bouncers are guys like
they're not even bouncers that they're
they're just dudes who are working so
now he he looks at he looks at and goes
now you don't think what he said was
offensive [ __ ] to my wife you want me
to get offensive now who'd he say that
to to the bouncer to the bigger guy who
was also the man okay he's like you kid
want me to get offensive now here's what
scared I was behind them I knew I was
gonna have to jump on you I was thinking
I was thinking rear naked choke yeah
good luck against Navy SEAL dude his
neck was he didn't have a neck and he
was so wide he's like he probably
weighed he was at eight he was Tim
Kennedy a little taller I'm not kidding
Tim Kennedy at six foot stick me up oh
you got problems
so I'm on my heart's racing because III
have to do something because none of
these other bouncers are and I'm not
gonna go do it
so he gets he gets in the guy's face and
he goes do you want me to you want me to
be offensive and what scared me was hit
his buddy and the guy's wife and the
buddy was big they were trying to calm
him down and it was and they were so
afraid they were afraid huh they were
afraid they're like oh no here's here
comes Carl they were terrified they were
like please please no don't is not
what's cooking they were like the way
you would don't please don't do his dog
like a huge dog that's growling at you
about the biter something and when I saw
a theory before yeah when I saw that I
went oh this is a disaster
oh um I don't know what to do at all Sam
please last time you wanted 4015 please
don't thank God the cops came
thank God unkind cops yeah well I was
that confrontational Wow
and he by the way this healing give a
[ __ ] this is a walk out is sealed the
way he moved out of that like he took
his sweet [ __ ] time
looked at the cops like this they knew
the cops knew what he was about they can
see everything well in that area too
it's like yes yeah he said he's innate
and but but like there are seals and
then there are the guys they're the
operators have been in the teams for a
long time and you're like yes you know
soul Snatchers he's got a he's got a
little satchel with a bunch of souls in
it I was just like [ __ ] dude I've seen
some crazy [ __ ] racist thing I've seen
yet that lady the the pro-nazi that's
the crazy thing I think Derek kept the
martini Davidoff and I had some some
times when we were young men we had some
weekend's there I cannae not uh I saved
the pantry ah I do like what we walk
around great coffee great food the best
the best the best you stay at the pantry
to the best man oh yeah this is fun good
good good good time great almost sold
out of the Wilbur guys get your tickets
by the way there's a car show right up
the street there I went to a car show in
the morning took my car up there had no
idea D'Elia was walking on stage to
2,200 people at the celebrity theater
it's a round theatre so you're
surrounded by everybody and I just hear
them after 15 minutes into my act I just
hear I don't know dude I don't think so
I don't think Adam I don't even like
this whole situation I'm like what the
[ __ ] no idea he Tex I had no idea
exactly the show here Thursday he takes
down Thursday Thursday night Brian chose
it frank caliendo's no it's Brian's
because do you think you'd care if I
coming you [ __ ] now I'd love it he goes
I guess he goes now let me for those of
you who don't know who I am
hahahaha sorry I'm Chris D'Elia
oh my god he goes now I played not this
theater than one I played a lot bigger
but it doesn't matter so that's wise
here's the thing
he was [ __ ] roast you I'll say that
and I'll say this I think crystal is
performance on last Thursday's podcast
is the funniest Esther parents we've
ever had you were laughing you your chin
was in your you were like laughing how
often do we laugh like that you were
just dying
you just whoa dude I did I know I gotta
be just the year a hundred percent
nightly I mean 100 percent how do you
how do you compete with that who wants
to compete with that he was and he was
on on like Rayong on on on I texted I
said you make me want to stop doing
stand-up comedy so he's the funniest
person got to have a boy a little boy
what you know I came over my house to
see Tiger I hose I guess my question
about being a dad and [ __ ]
that's great Tiger loved him Chris is
one of those guys he obsesses over
anything he does well he'll be a great
he's actually secretly super disciplined
oh never go away god Chris is never late
he's never show up every day he does
stand-up every single day yeah you know
what he met you Jitsu he showed up there
he goes I was there every single day for
three hours and I never got good because
it wasn't his thing but he's so [ __ ]
funny man look at him with his
sunglasses I knew he's gonna do that so
I wore mine till God he's funny
yeah to me that's the best performance
I'm firing the key I would agree I had
so many people tell me that it was so
[ __ ] funny I know it was so funny man
and he kept turning to feel you it my
bad yeah how about with your brother is
like move your legs please move your
legs you so tight stiff J was sitting
bolt upright I know both right everybody
here has a little cold appalling I don't
know if is a coldest something what
everyone's sick oh my gosh that bullet
you're for now but you're with although
I I'm I have the new formula I think
like I think like kid I think Boston has
it I used to get sick every four months
no matter what and now it's been almost
14 months but it's only because
sleeping I take naps and you know I do
too
but sometimes you know see it set just
the work it's just the work and not
sleeping and then you get like my kid
you think about it my kids especially
tigers around snotty-nosed [ __ ] these
parents man who let their kids go to
school with runny nose doctor [ __ ] all
over their hair when they don't do their
hair and like how do you not do your
kids here and drop off at school well
how the [ __ ] you dressed like that in
come to school how do you let you keep
come to school and pajamas in bed it the
[ __ ] are you doing yep like it's
coughing like maybe take the day off
maybe take the day off do you know the
only thing I and I fight about is I'll
get to the house no and you know cuz I
don't live there but I get to the house
and my dog Nico
my Corgi he's fat oh yo Tom wait yeah if
I'm gone for the weekend I come back
he's a little [ __ ] sausage and I'm
like who's over feeding my dog who's
over feeding my dog it's one of those
little things cause the prob I had to be
careful
you should get to him for your little
walks Roxy boxy yeah man when babies get
sick though that scares me
yeah I know Joanne I wanted me where I'm
asking like you out your damn mind he's
building his immune system it's trouble
in there like three weeks old though
trouble especially the flu babies died
with the flu a black long that's not
good I'll be all right dude excited for
Christmas man yeah I guess I know I
don't know what you asked what you asked
was air palm
I lost I've lost three you lost three I
lost to myself that's mean hey your pods
aren't for guys like you and me they're
not first I just get the ones with the
court now I don't need it okay as well I
don't need their pots [ __ ] you're
positive also I forget to charge them it
runs out of battery on the flight I seem
to do I died just I have a plug in I
just do plug [ __ ] your ear pods dead now
just plug well I'm gonna buy I'm gonna
buy some really expensive like
sound-canceling ones that you can put on
that are better
they're wise but wise I hate cords then
I don't know why I like cold iron
[ __ ] yeah what do you guys eat those
sort what are you
dr. dre and they have those big things
are you producing doesn't cool now hurry
up bring up cool-looking expensive
headphones let's see what I'm gonna buy
younger now I want Bose or beats by dre
would be the one those beats are not
good I talk to people that's all
marketing the photos are most expensive
oh no go back
what are those those aren't for you go
back go back Jim I'll show you the ones
right there five grand there you go
you're hold on mother of poo
where's for those abbess abyss right
this what the hell are those weird why
are they so expensive I mean that's
crazy
an 8-foot cable you'll be like dr. Dre
or not that's crazy though so we got
Santa for Christmas
hell no not spend that much money I'll
lose him I'll break all this I'll lose
them or break them that's what happens
to me sunglasses and [ __ ] headphones
nah man holidays are for the kids there
are for the kids I don't want any
presents also please don't wish me happy
married Chris I don't take you makers oh
don't do that
I don't like it best headphones all
right that's all propaganda though yeah
oh there we go
2:58 Sony know there's Bowie's noise
bose noise-canceling 700 o's are good i
get those gaelic ridiculous on the plane
i can't stand people you know like i
can't stand when people have the next
thing on so they can fall asleep and we
have the headphones come on guffy me god
are you [ __ ] going to outer space I
own every hour fly around the worst you
know who uses that next thing I was
gonna hear this present a nuts my
Derrick
my opener is the next thing he's
carrying it with him through the airport
Stevie blue eyes used to walk around
he'd have a he had a back like it was an
arch thing that he got a target and he
put that there and he just kept his back
straight like this all of that it's
pretty cool
I don't know he's made to just fly dude
yeah just [ __ ] once you use it it's
pretty good
now I'll use that just put your head on
the [ __ ] wall like everybody else
yeah but it feels good when you got a
little arch not weird feels nice you
know you know I didn't these these
chairs are comfy comes these are pretty
comfy
yeah just hot in here it is hot right
okay that's what I thought
Oh chin tried uh what do we have venison
sliders and warthog warthog spaghetti
bore the listen wild boar she had wild
bored pasta where and then chin had uh
it was some type of gaming me where were
you elk no it's called the restaurant
I'll know in a second oh yeah that place
we did I think you got uh uh what's the
drink that Jay has to have a synapse
absinthe perhaps Tanith where were you
in San Diego oh cool with some cool
restaurants down there uh nice great
restaurants Rogen gave me a shitload of
elk was it I said to the podcast and
he's like you want some milk he's got
three freezers just sausage steak I'm
like holy mother of god I love it
gonna start I must have taken my baking
my meat cooking he's so into it he's
gonna listen to how it things and the
Roasters and you know that dad it's like
I don't know what it is well they're
eggs yeah the green I think yes I chew
into a two chin what used to cook a lot
more he's always post cooking [ __ ] yeah
I want to say I think venison is my
favorite right now my favorite meat I
love it's venison it my friends a hunter
oh so you got a Utah buck ooh what did
it bro narrow you shot with bone a bone
gave you a bunch of meat you gave me a
bunch of meat I'm getting more to you
laughter this weekend yeah gotta have
some meat venison is amazing just salt
and pepper that's it that's all mmm I
know maybe a little garlic butter oh
it's probably the best I've ever had
I've never l can use Brie no I think
that's the best
killed in my future but dude used to
cook a lot more chin and posted and [ __ ]
really like doing like ramen on [ __ ]
yeah like cutting hot dogs in and stuff
remember that's delicious yeah I just
haven't done in a while and there's a
new ramen that I do now that's very
expensive but I have to make a video
about it what are you so expect yes each
one it's just it's very famous in Japan
your brother went there I went to the
actual place but they still instantly
how much amazing it's 30 bucks for the
box that you says Christ you always go
to Mountain MTN Ellison hearing go not
advocating it's [ __ ] Mountain ramen
ah okay ah porkbelly ramen forget it
[ __ ] the [ __ ] always amazing no I do
I've had MTN oh that's our boys rescue
haven't Travis not anymore I sold out
but I reduced it to Joey well it's like
we're not getting reservations anymore
oh damn that looks good that does look
fantastic
knock your dick that's doing time right
now egg out but yeah no eggs but one of
the best parts that looks fantastic
it's so authentically Japanese Travis
went and studied in Japan wow that looks
good there I haven't been there yes
their new restaurant huh yeah it's
really really cool if you're into
Japanese they got these Japanese yams
with miso butter you're like how the
[ __ ] sometimes things can change your
life like this every day
they'll change your life sorry I didn't
mean to matter ask Jill I'm being a
little traumatic those look nice though
um okay I drank too much coffee yeah
I gotta make oh Tommy egg take your
lunch I had a quad shot this morning oh
boy that's another double Jesus I worked
out in cold gym today this is
interesting
it's an interesting place to throw back
it smells like farts and protein powder
smells like farts and redline energy
drinks it's it's yeah it's um it is got
all those old-school body
there's still there man yep I saw its
cormier it was Chloe remember Chris
Cormier he's a trainer there yep he's
training there yep he's still huge and
and but old-school body builder
old-school 70s 80s 80s no 90 he's a
Lebanese yeah he was mr. Berlin yeah
he's like yeah like too late nineties to
say really oh yeah yeah well you use
Crisco me Olympia this guy right yeah
it's no joke yeah he's always around
he's still there yep Hey yep go go I'll
say that a lot of the women some of
those women there go Jim depressing dude
um you'll remember I grew up there right
my uncle pax was one of those guys Oh
little depressing you've been going
there cuz I was going there 27 years ago
25 years ago that 25 years for me and
you two but I was there when I was older
and I came back for the first time today
and I saw seen people's still their
faces just 25 years older it was what's
crazy
in the same workout gear yeah that's
true and you know we're like the spandex
you know it's because it's what when
they fell they would when they were at
their peers when they wore it and now
they're yeah yeah now that's he's
natural right look at that back you'll
catch Arnold in there
I talked to learn all about that works
out there yeah one get learned there yep
I won't say one because you've seen
Arnold in there I've seen I mean
everyone goes it's like a you know it's
a historic landmark do that but don't do
this is that is that who is that is that
that's same for me
Wow I want now there is nothing gay
about bodybuilding am i right nothing K
it's a man judging other men's physique
I will say this we have a posing room in
Gold's Gym I posing well I've been in
there I'm sure I'm not posing in there
with my uncle he'd forced me to pose
there with my shirt off see I didn't I
didn't know this chapter
Oh your life so you spent your summers
in van
and your uncle pax was a legit body belt
mr. universe he was mr. universe on mr.
universe
oh Jesus and my aunt was mrs. universe
so so I grew up in with with those
spandex Shaab no packs bill packs peel
PA sex Pat yup and then B Beals a BB al
there it is why don't we have a
different last name than your dad
because he's not he's uh was best way
now yeah he he married into the family
oh wow that's my aunt though that's
Sophie from there she's got good
genetics too by the way mrs. universe
that's an absolutely amazing outfit
that's you go through a big ya keep
calling he's like 70 there but he's nice
74 Dodd there 74 what 74 mr. universe
Wow
packs people what happened there was
that huh
he had a open heart surgery he had a
heart attack and that's when he got in
crazy shape Wow
doctor film look at that I'll use the
best made some cash to write uh-huh
uh-huh okay I mean they they basically
lived in [ __ ] you know Gold's Gym all
these Dan tastic those tights dude come
on
J you have me do the poses it made no
sense cuz I'd built like Kermit the Frog
but you looked up to him
well yeah he's my hero it's incredible
when I first moved to Venice he like he
had the when I was a grown man when I
moved to Venice Ikey let me stay at his
place right cuz I can afford to live
anywhere else so he let me stay at his
place and he goes my aunt was always
worried about it one let me stay there
he was like I'm a stator don't tell
anyone I'm Elysia here's the code again
stuff and he was all I ask is you tell
me the stories the girls you bring over
and [ __ ]
he's all that's a great uncle so I first
got a great uncle yeah I played that
cattle right there locks and Olympic
Trials he did yep stud played football
cow did a track at Cal big trial rock
boxing yeah super stud a shop stir yeah
he was the best man please Bart get that
outfit that's why I went there but when
he passed away and I knew they're gonna
flip the place I went there and got some
of his old stuff dude yeah he's the best
yeah he's hilarious PAC spheal
yeah Gold's is an interesting place you
see dudes to see a guy you're like big
good-looking guy but you know some
people just miss like you have your yeah
you have AG et on oh well yeah you know
wife-beater on tucked into your
sweatpants with like Jazzercise socks on
and you know end but you're also 35
what's going on what happened a lot of
broken dreams that finished there are
several you know if you see bigger
faster stronger you see those guys in
there and their vans and they're there
so there's some don't get me wrong
there's some great people there some
fantastic people course it's just it's
never it's it's very strange
I actually love it this is happy forever
but it's just like [ __ ] it's the guys
are the biggest guys in the world and
they're doing dumbbells that are 200 in
each and and then the girls have these
blah asses the shredded the Holden's
foot like insane shape Franco Columbu
dr. Franco Columbu got his ph.d very
close to Arnold he recently passed away
right yes he did he was so stupid strong
Arnold was not a small man take a look
at the tits on him no dude take a look
at the tits on him and then nervous
Franco hanging by his feet Franco was
doing that old-school functional fitness
way back when dude can you imagine being
Franco and Arnold in the [ __ ] 60s and
70s in Venice Beach in Gold's Gym
looking like I'm kind of famous Arnold
was a Mean Girls he [ __ ] they never
stopped don't look at him look at that
chick on the left I loved one that
everybody loved don't say our
bodybuilders not strong watch kind of
weight they put on on there I got my
friend was saying that is it they're not
strong I was like that guy specially 500
pounds
you don't know who'd say they're not
strong the girl's body when they don't
get so [ __ ] up that's a cool look
right there
dumped a pump tear dump day that's a
great [ __ ] look right there
it's tough man yeah that's what you see
a lot of though yeah so some some people
that just they they they're just missing
in some way so or they're not well the
cab's want to do you know that's all
they want to do sure which I can
appreciate yeah I wish I could agree cuz
it's not all I want to do it's the best
mustache I've ever seen great hair it's
very dark
you gotta love that guy that's a real
mustache yeah Arnold ter fantastic
Arnold was there was guy out there who's
made for bodybuilding it was Arnold yeah
he's made for Hollywood yeah made it
cool come on man look at that you
kidding me
that doesn't make you wonder steroid it
does like I think he looks good he's one
of those few guys as a bodybuilder no
body angle but but that was when Bobby
Brown they do whatever the all the deck
in the world and his genetics but yeah
now it's a beauty I mean now it's not
fun now it's like now there's so much
[ __ ] pharmacy ya know it's not like
Arnold's gonna live to an older age
these new these this new age like Ronnie
Coleman you have to have a complete hip
[ __ ] replacement like all the HGH and
these designer steroids now this guys
are [ __ ] it their heads are this big
now no one gives a [ __ ] about mr.
Olympia anymore it's the game has
changed man that's a bummer
yep did they just you know people know
when to stop start taking my
bodybuilding more seriously I started
talking to Rogan on Rogan about TRT
the number of people that hit me up with
advice like hey listen man I'm going to
a doctor I'm not you like you to do it
yes i dude
look at me do the money now meanwhile do
you know how I'm see what I'm doing it
now I [ __ ] my neck up today well I
keep exacerbating I gotta figure out
what's wrong I don't feel good
ah [ __ ] we're all low energy right now
my next door hang up everyone's sake you
keep talking on your neck every week I
now sick of it let's put some current
events hey wait a minute
kind of bailing huh I'd only hear about
your neck actually workouts sorry dude
no come on can't have your pubes growing
like wildfire you got a trim I'm up okay
it's only polite and this holiday season
we're gonna make it easy on you
manscaped perfect package 2.0 now let's
get the gift that everyone loves
I'm sure you've nicked your nuts have
dude all right as have I
you got a revolutionary company
manscaped maybe your mom has a mustache
you never know helps with that it does
they redesigned the electric trimmer
their lawn mower 2.0 has proprietary
advanced skin-safe technology so the
trimmer won't Nick or snag your nuts
dude waterproof by the way you can use
in the shower that's crazy
how about this package that comes with
the odorant for your nuts what you have
a crop preserver deodorant frizzy and
for your nuts also comes with some
manscape boxers it's a complete package
tis the season to manscape so get
yourself your dad your brother your mom
girl whatever whoever needs to shave the
bush the manscape perfect package 2.0
they got the crop Reviver and the crop
preserver yeah that's what I said dude
you twerps are off free shipping with
the code fighter at manscape calm your
balls will thank you get 20% off and
free shipping with the code fighter at
manscape calm that's 20% off with free
shipping and manscaped calm and use code
fighter which is what I am clean up your
nuts make Santa proud this year okay so
this one was submitted by David
Lopez and this woman in San Shi
originally from San Francisco
she went into a grocery store and she
tied her dog outside when she came back
out her dog was gone I thought you
dumbass I never quite yeah I never quite
understood why people would do that
because I feel like I don't feel really
cute dogs you can't bring your dog
inside so in San Francisco a miniature
Australian Shepherd yeah so right now
she is offering a seven thousand dollar
reward for the reappearance of her dog
and she's also she paid I believe it was
$1,200 for a plane to fly around with a
banner in that area asking for
information about her cause she loves
that dog can you see it with me it's
very it's a very real love I just need
to help damn I hope they find me to find
out if they found that dog let's see
what the latest it all so goddamn seven
grand I'd do it if I loved my dog that
much would you do it for your Corgi I
probably would I love that little [ __ ]
I bet I don't need wood the problem is
it's really hard to get your dog back
but I'd be like look no questions asked
I'll give you $7,000 for my dog back but
actually Tokyo would give them would do
it for seven grand
yeah for someone granya yeah but it's
just I just had me wait the money that I
finally steal a dog you [ __ ] well
people are terrible do nothing it tell
you what if you're an animal person
don't watch that new documentary on the
nepalese which one don't [ __ ] with cats
oh what's that about because cats are
are no joke they're cruel right they
kill birds really let's not watch the
trailer all right it's in there I play
it though it's the darkest documentary
I've seen my wife really mm-hmm
why play it for him
wait let me get the audio that la looks
like my grandma so scary cat lady dude
it's not about the [ __ ] cats Calif
torturing cats
he goes from cats to human it's so good
it's so well done
mom watch it right now it's watch it
right so got that video the cat
I don't J know whether you know Jake the
internet computer guy yeah I don't know
what it wasn't I sat down last night we
put the kid to bed I was a cow finally
relaxing turn around James like oh yeah
you might you might like this show and
I'm like oh I like serial killers [ __ ]
turn on they don't show the whole video
because they won't but the what pisses
everybody what gets somebody everybody
so riled up is you know those
vacuum-sealed type bags that you hit
like stuff and yeah well shows a guy
playing with the cute kittens he like
that's cute and what's the point he puts
him in there and murders
killed him and then it gets and then so
that that that those people are shown
you they see it like [ __ ] this dude
let's find this dude and so everyone's
looking for him and he realized he's
gonna attention for it so then he sends
on another video she was a little cat
like alright another cat then a Python
and it's like in a room it feeds a cat
the Python yeah her feet the Python yeah
but the cat and then you can see I mean
that goes down and then off he goes a
human he kills a human being oh yeah
shows it they don't show it on there you
can find it he was a human being uh well
he's a gay man and he puts a Craigslist
ad out and then and yeah I don't want to
spoil it for everybody
wow I gotta watch this Wow
some real statistics but what's
frustrating is that the team that top
video they do these people are fantastic
they go in like they find out where he's
at
don't show did I yeah it's okay okay
well they they find out you know don't
don't tell me oh I'm not but they found
out details and this team puts together
like all this information and they find
out where he's at and then go to the
police for so Montrell go hey
this [ __ ] dudes gonna start killing
people are telling you and they don't
even look into it until it gets so dark
we're finally the police like all right
what do you got
and they basically tracked him down for
it is signaled you know if there's a
well dialed pornography these people
that parents is father's it's they that
there are something I've had a good two
million images see 48 million images so
it's like it's the four cops it's like
oh you you oh you know what we deal with
and like it's crazy that's crazy
but I agree this one's nuts you watch
there's like whole I can't wait to watch
it
the creepiest part is is you know
they're trying to find like information
about and they think they found them and
the one lady works in casinos and he
uploads a video and it's a video him
behind her as she's working whoa I gotta
watch this that's good
guy was a real psycho man yeah of course
he just gets off on his mom's teeth in
your teeth are very similar I'll say
that I'll save that
I don't spoil I know I'm saying so this
mom have the exact same bottom blue
yellow right now let's say your teeth in
her I was like oh that's Brian calm down
dude you have worst teeth and I do you
we know this right wait a minute
do you remember when the studio over
here come on in the studio face you to
use candid come here right no show the
bottom no no I'll show you bottoms come
on
we don't yell on crooked but they're not
cooking the other you are and look at
this hold on take a picture of mine took
a toast look at those [ __ ] things now
open your mouth a little bit bro nope
that's it oh yeah can you do this yeah
you got some issues let me see we just
put a side-by-side chin and Brian's had
work done well no I hadn't don't say
work I work your clear eyes were out I
were in vision for don't say like I had
worked on it's not
you have a beautiful teeth now have
enough and they're still not good that's
Jukes I stopped wearing him at night I
got to start wearing him again I'm gonna
go to candidate for real because I
didn't like Invisalign a much less need
whitener yeah I should watch that dot
though I'd make I'd save it for after
holidays I post about like great Doc
wait car great and yeah the darkest yeah
I don't like when you see that stuff out
there in the world dick oh I know
there's a whole dark web full of that
[ __ ] minutes just makes you sad do
they show I don't want you to give
anything away but did they show the
scene but blurred out when he kills the
dude mmm they show right before oh yeah
I'm not gonna watch it no like my girl
as soon as the cat thing the most
graphic thing that shows the cat with
the Python yeah which at least one of
the animals getting fed that was then my
girl as soon as the cat that she's like
I'm going all right I don't know holiday
drama created the space for us here's
what it will actually do yep so we
officially have six military branches
now and we're gonna it's the new branch
is called space force it's gonna be
working along with the Air Force but a
lot of what they're gonna be dealing
with is gonna pertain to satellites and
knowledge and space oh yeah
the six branch of the US Armed Services
that's sick yes force oh yeah and
they're starting out with 16,000 people
in the first group and everyone's gonna
be hand-picked yes oh yeah 700 three
billion dollars that's only huh just so
they can basically scramble information
no so here's the space do know it's also
satellite technology so communications
yeah they're trained to basically level
the field with what China and Russia is
doing oh yeah Wow and robotics is the
other frontier where it's a kind of a
race to see who can come up with the
best robots to find that'd be cool if
you're one of the first that freakin
part of [ __ ] space force right
it sounds so cool dude so cool I was
shot sparse space wars we missed that
boat humpy I know I have no interest in
going to space no zero not yeah you know
what was the thing that Ilan must said
you you can go to space Mars Mars but
you never he said that yeah right now
he's working on trying to colonize Mars
but everybody who's gonna be going on
the first trip
they will never be allowed to come back
why they don't have the resources to do
a trip there and back so if you're going
here there for good enjoy that well
who's gonna do that oh there's a bunch
of people I'm sure sign up for I think
it's a bunch of rich people ID enough
food for the you have to wait on pods I
don't know that's a great that's scary
man what else you got so I don't for
some reason this past weekend there were
so many different like celebrity nude
leaks there was a huh wasn't it fake
the Steph Curry one was fake cuz the guy
in the video of that was leaked it
didn't have the same tattoos so that one
was fake the baby says that his was fake
as well cuz he says he doesn't send
nudes but people are pretty sure it's
him and then ASAP Rocky
he had a leak on pornhub under like
somebody put up amateur porn and they
put it under like like white girl big
black hawk and in the video you see the
guys hand and you see a tattoo that ASAP
rocky also has and as he's moaning he
has a very distinct voice so people are
like wait I'm pretty sure that's ASAP
Rocky and within a couple hours all the
videos were taken down which makes
people think that they it was definitely
him
but a lot of people are also bummed out
that it's probably him cuz it didn't
seem like he was doing real well really
no we're not doing well um it was very
underwhelming
really yeah they have a piece on them
that's a bigger question yeah he had a
pretty good piece on him but to be fair
it was also the girl wasn't doing much
okay she's just not laying on a
lackluster video sure yeah the other
thing is what they're able to do now is
they're putting like celebrity faces
mm-hmm so like Kristen Bell was one or
like they bunch of like celebrity that
looks very real yeah yeah Wow do you
think anything that he aims yes sounds
video we're two years away from that
being indecipherable like you know it's
crazy
that's nuts this is all part of it yeah
Wow okay okay so Instagram and Facebook
are now updating their branded content
and they are now not allowing people to
do pay promotions with vape tobacco and
guns maybe they've even incorporated CBD
into that oh really
using looting just right now they're
good it's like it's some legal thing
they're going to see BB CBD be legal
soon I Instagram you're good Facebook
you can't you can post Instagram can
post YouTube you can't do CBD but you're
going to take it all down it's not gonna
last too long it'll be back soon but
they've makes sense with kids a big
social media is that vitamin E oil when
you when you heat it the vitamin E oil
coach your lungs you school and you die
and it's it was done in like sort of not
in the bigger companies but it's it's
like you know some of the cheaper than
Hillary's they were using oh yeah kind
of crazy the amount of kids who jewel is
insane no I know
yeah that jewel the bagels they like the
brand
oh yeah jewel is the most popular form
of vaping right now but jewel jewels not
been in that in any of the cases right
yeah they're getting sued of the man
once consumed and the originator of it
came out was I
okay I lied I thought like it's this not
good cuz jewel was like the first like
really big powerhouse to come in and do
all the fun flavors and the branding was
good yeah hi everybody I see is vaping I
feel like I'm feeling less of it yeah I
don't see it
I think it's within a younger crowd I
don't really see too many older people
vaping or at least vaping Jules yeah I I
it's so funny because I raped a couple
times of weed I wanted to go to sleep
and then I was like I looked at that oil
I thought to myself I don't know who put
that oil in there and I don't know
what's in the [ __ ] oil I remember
that I was like and then I also know
because I know some people that grow
weed on it on a large scale they spray
the [ __ ] out of it and you have to
remember when they when they must decide
oh yeah like they spray it every day
they spray this [ __ ] out and then when
they put it they tape the leaves
they have to make sure it doesn't mold
they had go through another process like
that so this you know then so well then
when you extract the oil I don't know
enough about any I don't know anything
about it but I would imagine that this a
lot of that that you're smoking a lot of
that [ __ ] pesticide too and a lot of
it gets in the wall I would imagine and
people can say you don't but you I don't
know where your lab is mm-hmm
now if it's a really big company like
med men or one of those companies I
trust them because they have a very
vested interest in keeping things very
very on the up-and-up because they can't
afford to have something like that
happen but I bought it mine from there
like indica to help you sleep
yeah so the oil thing I bought that from
Mad Men because I figured that was like
a more reputable brand yeah I don't know
it still feels weird when I do it all it
gets stuck there too yeah I have edibles
too but I don't I don't know how to use
them really yeah I just I just easily
it's such a zombie it just makes me are
you good with it uh I don't like being
high why'd you at night either Brogan
this time did you walk no I was like I'm
not going near the house I'm let's come
pick you up I here to come pick me up I
couldn't Drive
neither wait six hours I ate a steak I
watched you make a steak I don't
anything I hate a grill you didn't eat
I didn't even watch them make wanted I
can cause an uber and then I had to wait
in my car I ate some warms disaster
missile design get high this time
grandma
but you didn't smoke this time no I'd
smart
no I don't know what's in there was that
means Rogen's weed so it's strong it's
not for amateurs I guess I did hang from
a bar for 2 minutes and 18 seconds that
wasn't bad thank you
let's get you this uh Britta lost
British Belgian Malinois oh yeah it's
just really cool what this dog did so
this is an assault suspect and then the
way the dog jumps into this window cuz
the guy didn't want to get out of his
car yes there's SiC the dog on them and
you see how the dog gets into the car
this is Duke in action yeah he didn't
care about the glass that's when Duke
made his holy hit they hit sleepy I try
to hit that yeah they hit they they hit
sleeves so hard that they can break
their own neck there that game so they
inhale asleep so when you have when
you're by training your dog you got to
have a handler that can give you don't
have some got a big eye pushing into it
because you can hurt the dog because
they inhale asleep like they'll bite
with their back teeth so that's why like
they're so game and they they can jump I
think they can jump better than any
other dog they're just they can scale
walls their [ __ ] wait I do he just took
the starter stalking I heard also
assaults oh wow yeah not great obviously
obviously a guy who's used to violence
did the relief thing by the way after he
after that dog bit him and he took him
down like that he was still he was still
talking and fight you still like [ __ ]
you you know suffered minor injuries
well alright this is to Carnival cruise
ships colliding okay somebody was
drinking I don't know how this even
really happened but this is near the
dock and you could see it's very slow
motion but it's quite a bit of damage
it's are so bad for the ecosystem
see that the back windows but the thing
to take away from this is the people
yelling it's annoying so he's afraid
that this boats gonna hit them they were
filming farther by yeah yeah that's how
you find out your friends real that's
exactly right
hey situations huh you panic one of
thousands of guards away free and that
boats moving super slow you're a real
[ __ ] remind me not to call you ever if
there's any kind of my takeaways like
his friends a giant [ __ ] Wow Ronnie
let's call you even if there's a
thunderstorm you [ __ ] I gotta [ __ ]
that but they said it's still seaworthy
so they can still float on the water but
it's just damage to get a repair but I
wouldn't trust and go out another gas mm
I don't [ __ ] with cruises
well I get seasick and you're stuck in
the boat for a long time it's just a
hotel and I don't like it no me neither
and I don't like it this sucks for a lot
of girls and maybe even like your boy
Stevie I don't know how he does it but
PayPal is pulling their business for
pornhub so you know usually you could
just send them money through PayPal
would they get God suddenly what happen
I don't know they did they actually
didn't give it a reason why but many
people are allowed PayPal but you can
their money will then moans yeah you
have to use something else
no PayPal's like the note like for sure
they'll figure it out so they still get
paid like fans only calm or whatever all
right I just thought this was
interesting Michael Bay I guess when Ben
Affleck was gonna do that movie
Armageddon he had baby teeth so they
actually got him new teeth for that role
$20,000
yeah veneers are not cheap man [ __ ] when
there's let me see his teeth Amana noisy
indifferent sir yellow over the years
yeah yellow for sure it's fine
just in back then you know face gets
puffy then that's it just does hi face
grows the net he taught you night and
day different day huh looks like me on
the right you on the left yeah he was a
thin kid on the left oh man he's always
pretty big they need to get older yeah
yeah these are legit six four eyes
amazing man you think about the movies
he's done I think I'm at the movies he's
directed he's really become a town yeah
and Bargo yeah six four gone girl a big
fella ya Gong crows great he's amazing
man I'm such a fan of it I hear he's a
great guy too
I got my friend Gavin O'Connor directed
I'm into the account well I took a movie
to awesome and you want to close it off
for just one more any would do you
another hand I was only six one thought
he was 64 who's that super super all
Henry camp now I've seen him six ones
being generous - what yeah I was at a
bar with him really there's just a quick
one with Bill Cosby why were you guys
able to watch this at SNL well you know
Eddie Murphy returned yeah you like the
bottom ugh what just like the monologue
Jesus not so sorry
ooh I hope Kelly at six wasn't that
amazing though right no what you Brian
online no he definite sit but of course
okay um yeah everyone on lines freaking
out about it it was cool that like
Chappelle Chris Rock and bootie watch it
it's just like yeah is all right so Bill
Cosby's mad on his publicist but if you
read this is a very long one but it's
actually funny how he talks about Cosby
but I'm not reading that yeah oh come on
sad mr. Murphy you're turning into a
race thing you [ __ ] idiot yeah he
said that you're turning into racing
stars I can get
comics can't make fun of Bill Cosby cuz
they're black what are you talking about
what are you talking about the guy the
guy had 19 or 20 women come for a rug to
me more than that yes 60 what do you
talk about Eddie all Eddie Murphy said
that if you would have told me 30 years
ago last time I didn't live you told me
30 years ago Bill Cosby be in prison for
he would be a live at home dad one would
think that mr. Murphy was given his
freedom to leave the plantation how
crazy could make his own decisions but
he decided to sell himself back to being
a Hollywood slave you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] who wrote this
step in fact ago these are these are the
dumb hashtag not funny SNL hash tag far
from finished
hash tag free bill just as is very old
God dude he's never getting out you say
so you can't make fun of a [ __ ]
serial rapist I guess because he's black
and you're black okay yeah and and
you're not and you're being what an
Uncle Tom or something get the [ __ ] out
of here
what what a bankrupt thing how about
Harvey Weinstein talking about how he
gave women their opportunity first you
see this he was like I was the first guy
to give them their opportunity I hired
female directors before it was cool and
yeah alright did you got 90 women that
you this isn't a give them opportunity
yeah would you say he's embarrassed you
heard that video or nothing via the the
recording of him begging for that girl
to come to his room of course it was a
stupid recently it was like one of the
things yeah please a competitive piece
of [ __ ] yeah all right last one this is
going viral right now because people
don't know which way this person is
swinging have you guys seen this okay no
now do you think he's swimming swinging
towards the building or swinging towards
us okay
everyone's saying that he's swinging
towards the building and towards some
people are saying it's half and half I
can see both do you see the dog-cart
doesn't look like he's swinging towards
the building or towards us
he's swinging towards us unless it's
somebody behind them
right I'll bet you 500 ollars cash right
now will you talk to watch a thousand
times I thought it was $1.00 one way I
think us people can't figure it out they
said legs are a hair they see how his
legs are he's go like this yeah he's not
able to do his legs the other way so why
am i watching this who can't have too
dumb question swinging away from the
[ __ ] building I'm mad now his legs
are purple
I'm Way too busy for this question
chance of the stupidest [ __ ] up Jim this
is king dammit case solved how's this a
thing people can't decide with a screen
there are not room when you're on
mushrooms all wait so you guys are both
saying the whole saying swing away from
the building cuz his [ __ ] legs or
legs are proponents his labor attached
the opposite his body
now watch now how human beings are bills
stupid watch it again watch again
imagine him swinging towards the
building that gifts feet are face go no
do you see it now no I don't see it now
Jim I sure don't alright never mind I
see what you're talking about but it I
don't know he's clearly going to a
sports yeah I said towards us to it but
then when I look at it differently well
that's because you wanna cause me x2
bats swinging away and that's pretty
much all the tournament's one really
quick update granted this poll has only
been up for like 20 minutes but there
have been a hundred and forty seven
votes saying that Brian has the worst
the the worst teeth out of you both
after meanwhile you have 317 Brendan oh
I have more yeah so if you think that
your teeth are worse oh wow
I know i won how many do I have a
hundred and forty say [ __ ] you guys okay
all 147 of y'all [ __ ] do you aegis
just be real though no one's teeth is
great here no I know but I beat you
better at over half though I've been
athlete more than half people give you
your old is that crazy I'll get Brian
more I'm sort of 300 how many people
hate him I hate my teeth 307
I hate that they hate the [ __ ] people
- yeah
what's the word you gotta get some win
here though you know what yeah you get
some win yeah I'll slap you around
Boston we're almost sold out it's very
excited literally almost sold out there
couple tickets left for the Boston
Wilbur and New Year's so go get your
tickets Nashville it's on baby the
January 10th and 11th I am there at
Zanies Nashville January 10th and 11th
get your tickets now at T fat K calm I'm
Oklahoma's yeah Oklahoma City this
Friday two shows only then Saturday Hard
Rock Casino Tulsa Oklahoma
don't worry sooner boomers my show is
after the big BCS game so you can come
to the show at the Hard Rock Casino this
Saturday but Oklahoma City this Friday
two shows the New Year's Eve New Year's
Eves New Year's Eve I'm at the Ice House
in Pasadena two shows eight o'clock ten
o'clock show gonna pop bottles bringing
2020 with your boy the thick crust
January gets pretty spicy count Foxwoods
Connecticut January 10th Boston Wilbur
January 11th San Jose improv the 17th
through the 19th then I close out in
Charlotte the 23rd to 25th get your
tickets at t f @k tom that i--dude i Ted
body's wheat teeth this the finala kid
we're out